des militaires en uniforme ont annoncé
en direct à la télévision publique avoir
pris le contrôle du pays brut explique
en moins d'une minute la situation au
burkina faso victime d'un coup d'état
militaire lundi 24 janvier le président
roch marc christian kaboré a annoncé
plus tard dans une lettre manuscrite sa
démission les militaires ont dissous le
gouvernement ainsi que l'assemblée
nationale et suspendu la constitution
ils se sont engagés lundi à proposer
dans un délai raisonnable un calendrier
de retour à un ordre constitutionnel
accepté de tous suite à leur prise de
pouvoir des centaines d'habitants de
ouagadougou la capitale sont descendus
dans les rues pour célébrer depuis
plusieurs mois le président kaboré été
critiqué pour son incapacité à contrer
les attaques jihadistes